oh look at that you're here welcome to
the show i'm bruce jenner
i kid but since caitlyn isn't using it i
figure why not it's like a box seat at a
ball game if it's empty might as well
move in from the cheap sheet cheap
sheets
[Music]
anyway but in all seriousness you gotta
hand it to caitlyn because it took balls
the size of weather balloons to
criticize media darling and trans
swimmer leah thomas saying biological
boys should not compete against
biological girls
jenner may not be on the cover of
wheaties anymore but she should be the
spokesperson for planters because she's
got some major nuts on her
by the way wheaties is the worst tasting
cereal ever it makes count chocula taste
like a 60 steak i think that's why they
put athletes on the box because no fat
person would dare eat it
now jenner says she has no beef with
thomas but felt the ncaa wasn't tough
enough in allowing thomas to compete in
women's races and she's right thomas
just beat a bunch of biological girls in
the 500 meter whatever
honestly i don't follow it swimming is
for people too lazy to bathe after
exercising
sorry trace
but in this controversy of letting
biological males be biological females
there has to be a sane position to take
first i don't think a dude chooses to
switch genders in order to beat girls in
the sport that you know before he sucked
at
because cheating with steroids would be
just much easier but remember as a dude
thomas was ranked at 462 one spot ahead
of her rusty anchor
and now as a chick she's number one she
should be the spokesperson for chlorine
strong enough for a man but made for a
woman
but i wonder if the controversy matters
to her or does she try to ignore it
i try to ignore it as much as i can
i trying to focus on my swimming
uh what i need to do to get ready for my
races
and just try to block out everything
else
okay that's weirdly selfish it's like me
putting on a dress and doing the view
and acting like it's no big deal
the sad thing is i'd still be the
hottest
but i'd also kick their butts it's not
hard it's the view they need tech
support to count to ten
but it's not about switching genders at
all that's just a distraction i doubt
winning swim meets is the reason anyone
would change their sex swimming is hard
enough i won't go near a kiddie pool
unless there's a lifeguard on duty
but it's about what you do after
switching genders it's common sense you
might even call it common courtesy
perhaps what thomas is doing is a
byproduct of masculine selfishness like
eating the entire pizza you were
supposed to save for your spouse when
she got home from work that's the
striking part a dude becomes a man and
then kicks the crap out of girls of the
sport it's just piggish i mean not many
women are becoming men and doing the
same thing or if they do they lose more
often than hillary clinton
so the more thomas wins as a chick the
more of a chauvinist she appears to be i
mean you should see that even if your
bangs are in your eyes
no one is saying it's wrong for you to
pursue the sport you love but when you
have a clear advantage and for some
reason you don't care it's disrespectful
and it's narcissistic
but by sticking up for women jenner
shows the respect she has for the fairer
sex which seems missing with leah as she
happily destroys the competition
and jenner's doing it in the face of a
media who condemns caitlyn while they
desperately cling to the untenable woke
position
an nbc op-ed actually compared thomas to
jackie robinson
which is weird they don't look at all
alike
except maybe in size and muscle mass
rika giorgi not sure if i got that right
a virginia tech swimmer took issue with
the nc2a rules allowing transgender
women to compete against biological
females after she missed the cutoff for
the consolation final in the 500
freestyle she blamed thomas thomas's
dominance in the race
in a letter she claimed their rules are
harmful to biological females and that
every event transgendered athletes
competed in was one spot taken away from
biological females herself included
you know it's almost as though
biological women should have their own
league so they aren't crushed by
biological men
that's crazy
ron desantis isn't he the commissioner
of swimming or something
he's also pretty ticked off
now the ncaa uh is basically taking
efforts to destroy women's athletics
they're trying to undermine the
integrity of the competition
and they're crowning somebody else uh
the woman's champion and we think that's
wrong
so he issued a proclamation declaring
the second place finisher floridian emma
wyant
the true champion
but in short leah crushed the female
competition i'm not devastated but then
i'm not a woman who swam all her life
competitively i'm just a biological male
who drinks competitively and i got the
trophies and liver to prove it
swimming is something i do when i need
to pee at the beach
it's true i'm just warming the water for
everybody else
but i'm looking at this and i can't deny
what i see
the nc2a seems more interested in
appearing woke than protecting its
athletes
but to make this ideology work you have
to erase the distinction between trans
and biological women that means it's not
only women being erased from the record
books of their own sports they're being
erased period no pun intended since men
can have periods too
so wait till the next leah thomas comes
along and wants to play a contact sport
like maybe women's lacrosse and leaves a
trail of injured women on the field
maybe then the nc2a and their lawyers
will finally say uncle
or should i say ant
let's
welcome tonight's
guests
one gallagher's known for smashing
melons but this one is known for
smashing good looks chief breaking news
correspondent trace gallagher
he knows the doj like i know the voj
that's vodka and orange juice to you
former white house national security
council aide kasp patel
and she's former centerfold for wine
enthusiast magazine fox news anchor
julie
and like windows in her drug dealer's
car she's always blacked out
fox news contributor cat tomb
all right i gotta go to trace cause
you're this the first time you're on the
new show it's good to see you you
claimed in the green room our spacious
green room where we have the hot tub
that you discovered me explain i tell
everybody who who loves your show look i
discovered the guy and they're like come
on i said listen me and julie and i'm
glad julie's in the show tonight had
this show 16 no coincidence called
studio b weekend and roger ailes calls
me and he says listen i got this guy
greg gutfeld he's going to come down
there put him on the show it's going to
be great he's uh he's kind of political
and really funny well turns out he was
really political and kind of funny
a little bit he came on and literally
torched hillary clinton
i mean torched her and i thought oh my
god i said greg shouldn't we have
evidence before you say that she was
given orders to john gotti i
i don't quite get the connection there
he's like i'm ready to do something so
the next time you came on i said maybe i
told the producer maybe we should
balance this guy out a little bit get
somebody else who is so yes
i
julie banderas and i discovered greg
gutfeld and now greg's got 19 shows and
his hacked buddy has to beg to get on
this one yeah i think we've come full
circle uh you discovered me and i'm
ending your career
trey
quickly i want to ask you you are we're
actually a pro athlete you were a
professional water skier i was i bet you
looked great uh it wasn't it was i had
the picture yeah oh i have some believe
me on the ceiling of my apartment which
you'll see later
do biological differences matter do
biological differences matter in water
skiing competitive water skiing uh you
know there were there were there were
men on the team that would wear the
female uh outfits but that was by design
because there were a couple of funny
skits and the thing but
no that the the girls would climb the
pyramid they would be on the top and the
men on the bottom because they're bigger
and it really in the whole concept of
this is you have to come down on
desantis side on this because it's
really not leah thomas's fault at least
i think right because uh you know she
she got the testosterone thresholds
right she waited the two years did the
thing it's all the nc2a the nc2a screwed
this up they thought it was a little bit
of science just like covet throw a
little bit of science and a lot of
politics and you can get this whole
thing covered the nc2a needs to
accommodate this they need to come up
with either an open category they need
to make the rules fit so that these
girls and i'm a father of two daughters
that these girls don't waste their whole
lives and have someone he's six foot one
right he's got a longer arm reach you
have to take a bigger shoulder she's got
a longer armor he was reading a bright
shoulder today probably right shoulders
the whole
dynamically it's the whole thing where
you know in two years you will see the
university of southern california will
have a men's 15th best tennis player
will wait two years
identify as a female play on the women's
team and his server her serve will still
be 150 miles per hour where the woman
serve as 120 miles per hour these are
astronomical differences that have to be
worked out but do you buy that julie do
you think anybody's really going to
switch in order to win in sports no i
don't think that she switched in order
to win in sports and let me just say
because i am a you know journalist so i
have some facts here um yeah before
sweet switching speaking of switching to
the women's team and i don't mean the
women's team biologically okay i just
want to make sure i i don't want to lose
you here um she was ranked 462nd when
competing with other men right
so and by the way this past saturday
night in my monologue she oh i went
listening no i was but i was staring at
cats she looks so hot tonight also she's
she placed last in the 100-yard
freestyle over the weekend as well so
her collegiate career is kind of over i
say she go into golf or curling
and i too by the way identify as male
but you can call me she it's fine and i
love peeing in the ocean and that's the
only reason i swim as well so we have
that in color oh that's beautiful i feel
really warm around you you should but
listen i can i just say william thomas
was one of the best on the men's team on
the men's team at penn he william thomas
two years ago was among the best so he
was among the best swimmers at penn 462
in the nation right he did really well
as a man which even makes it worse
because he was one of the top men came
over clearly he is dominating in the
field i had no idea they knew so much
about this cache do you know a lot about
this topic i thought you're the only
switch hitter in the room so i expected
you to win
i think the ncaa is only beat out by
corruption by fifa and the international
olympic committee
but i always you know as a guy who
desperately tried to get into d1 college
sports and nobody recruited me except
one football team um i ended up being a
cheerleader so i would have a
cheerleader no no um i was a guy that
got drunk at college basketball games
and led a lot of cheers back okay so
sort of oh that makes me a cheerleader
then yeah yeah see you identity you
identify as a cheerleader
i do but the only thing uh the only
thing i actually am like sort of baffled
by is what is title ix for now like i
don't understand we put in so much time
and money on title ix rightly so i think
in a lot of areas to give women's sports
equal funding equal scholarships equal
opportunities as men's sports so
do we now cross-fund do they give
scholarship slots to
women for men and men for women i just i
just think they obliterated title ix in
a matter of weeks
and they didn't think that through it's
new ground they're breaking cat do you
have any solutions for this is it conan
drum or conundrum conundrum great job
thank you
conundrum i've never actually said that
word out loud i always wanted to i think
i broke new ground i think i'm the real
hero here probably right
uh like so
honestly i am like i am terrified to
talk about this and then i think that
when i find myself wishing that i could
instead talk about like a literal
murderous war because that feels less
touchy to me than a college women's
swimming competition that maybe like the
way we approach this discourse is
there's a problem there because
obviously transphobia is bad i don't
doubt that leah thomas has had to face
transphobia and i think that's wrong
also you mentioned the qualifications
that you know you the usa swimming rules
there was new ones that were put into
place not for ncaa not for ncaa but that
she likely would not have qualified
under those rules so there are
legitimate reasons to have questions
about this that have nothing to do with
transphobia and i think it's
bad to just blanket label anyone who
says anything short of you go girl as
transphobic not just for the
biologically female athletes but also
for people who want trans acceptance
because there are a lot of people who
have questions about this who have
concerns about this think maybe this
wasn't fair who
are not allowed to say that and that is
not acceptance
uh if anything that can prevent
acceptance because it breeds a lot of
resentment it's just fake yeah and i but
i go back my original point is why can't
we separate the issue of can and should
just because you can't do something
doesn't mean you should but i always do
i know that is true all right up next is
your salad or chicken wrap more pricey
due to inflation crap